SINGING HIS PRAISES DON'T.
REACTION FROM ALL SIDES.
EKE
EK
WE BEGIN WITH JOHN ROBERTS LIVE
ON THE NORTH LAWN.
>> IN A PHONE CALL TO ME LAST
NOVEMBER, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE SAYING I
WANT TO START A WAR.
I AM NOT TRYING TO START A WAR,
I AM TRYING TO PREVENT ONE.
NOW CRITICS WHO WERE ANGRY OVER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S GET TOUGH
APPROACH TO NORTH KOREA ARE
SAYING, WELL, MAYBE HE WAS
RIGHT.
>> SOUTH KOREAS OFFICIALS
CREDITED THE PRESIDENT'S MAXIMUM
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN FOR BRINGING
NORTH KOREA TO THE TABLE.
THE PRESS SECRETARY HAPPILY
AGREED.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME THE UNITED STATES IS
ACTUALLY HAVING CONVERSATIONS
FROM A POSITION OF STRENGTH, NOT
A POSITION OF WEAKNESS LIKE THE
ONE THAT NORTH KOREA FINDS
ITSELF IN DUE TO THE MAXIMUM
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN.
>> THE TURNAROUND WAS STUNNING.
THE TWO LEADERS TRADED INSULTS
FOR MONTH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLING KIM A
MANIAC AND LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
KIM FIRED BACK THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS MENTALLY DERANGED.
EVEN THE SECRETARY OF STATE WAS
TAKEN ABACK BY HOW QUICKLY THE
LANDSCAPE CHANGED.
>> WHAT CHANGED WAS HIS POSTURE
IN A VERY DRAMATIC WIN THAT WAS
A SURPRISE TO US.
HE WAS SO FORWARD LEANING.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS DON'T
WHY KIM DID THE ABOUT-FACE BUT
THEY BELIEVE THE SANCTIONS WERE
CRIPPLING THE REGIME.
REACTION TO THE ANNOUNCEMENT WAS
ALMOST ALL POSITIVE.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT THIS STEP IS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
CERTAINLY IT IS REQUIRED TO
NORMALIZE THE SITUATION AROUND
KOREA.
>> THE PROMISE OF A ONE-ON-ONE
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
A VICTORY FOR KIM JONG-UN.
THE WHITE HOUSE WARNING THAT KIM
WON'T GET A FACE-TO-FACE UNLESS
HE GIVES UP HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR.
THE UNITED STATES MADE ZERO
CONCESSIONS.
NORTH KOREA MADE SOME PROMISES.
THIS MEETING WON'T TAKE PLACE
WITHOUT CONCRETE ACTIONS THAT
MATCH THE PROMISES MADE BY NORTH
KOREA.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AWARE THAT
THE OFFER FROM KIM JONG-UN COULD
BE ANOTHER RUSE TO BUY TIME TO
COMPLETE HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
SENATOR RUBIO IS SKEPTICAL
PLAYING OUT WHAT KIM MAY BE UP
TO.
>> LURING US INTO NEGOTIATIONS
BUT HE WILL MAKE DEMANDS WE CAN
NEVER AGREE TO LIKE THE U.S.
ABANDONING SOUTH KOREA.
HE WILL SAY I WAS REASONABLE AND
MET WITH THE PRESIDENT AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH ME.
>> AS THE WORLD CONSIDERS THE
POTENTIAL FOR A HISTORIC U.S.
AND NORTH KOREA BILATERAL, THE
ATTORNEY FOR STORMY DANIELS
REVEALED THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY COHN USED A
TRUMP EMAIL TO NEGOTIATE WITH
DANIELS.
IT WAS NOT CONNECTED TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BUT DANIEL'S ATTORNEY SAYS IT'S
EVIDENCE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
KNEW ABOUT THE AGREEMENT.
THE IDEA THAT MR. COHN WAS DOING
THIS FOR HIS CLIENT MR. TRUMP
BUT TRUMP KNEW NOTHING ABOUT IS
RIDICULOUS.
HE SAID DANIELS WON'T GET OUT OF
THE GAG ORDER.
ON NORTH KOREA, ONE OF THE BIG
REMAINING QUESTIONS IS WHERE
COULD A MEETING TAKE PLACE?
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS TRYING TO
WORK OUT A LOCATION SAY IT'S
COMPLICATED.
IT LIKELY WOULD NOT BE UNITED